Cette invention va changer votre vie
Il y a presque un an, je me suis rendu au Japon en quête de salles arcades...
UFO Catcher....
Borne Mario Kart....
Fléchettes....
Dance Dance Revolution....
Tous ces objets si rares en France...
Sont beaux, récents et flambant neufs là-bas...
Et ils marchent bien!
Cela fait maintenant plusieurs mois que je ne rêve plus que d'une chose....
Y retourner...
(Squeezie 2) : Salut énorme merde!
Y a plus besoin d'aller au Japon pour faire des UFO catchers!
Allez saluuuuuuuuuut!!
(Vrai Squeezie) : QUOI?
Les amis nous sommes sur AKIBA CATCHER c'est un site web où nous sommes connectés à des putains d'UFO catchers en direct du Japon
Et on les contrôle à distance pour tenter de gagner les figurines qu'ils contiennent
Y en a qui vont se ruiner *rires*
Quand je suis allé au japon en mars dernier, j'ai chopé peut-être trente objets dans les UFO catchers...
Petite image preuve a l'appui attention, il y a de tout, des figurines, des peluches et de l'arnaque dans l'air
Bref, ça coûte 1.90€ l'essai au lieu de 1€ au Japon
Mais, t'as les frais de livraison gratuits
Je veux qu'on chope....
Une figurine aujourd'hui !
Ok ! Celui la c'est pour gagner un putain de..d'amiibo de pack ou de figurine j'en sais rien bref...
Il faut faire tomber une boule dans ce trou là
Allez vas-y premier essai c'est parti. Hé ça va être, mais..
Mais mec une boule c'est impossible à attraper mon gars ! Bon vas-y
On va tester, c'est parti !
Ho mais c'est maximum c'est abusé comment
c'est dur ! Ya un délai d'batard ! Non mais mec !
C'est abusé l'délai! J'dois doser sans même voir !
*RIRE* C'est scandaleux mais on va jamais gagner...
Un truc ! Un.........Deux
Trois, on est en plein dessus ! Et est-ce qu'on..
Ho putain ! On a eu tout au fond mais vous avez vu le lag!
Mais c'est un scandale! Est-ce qu'on en a une? Non mais là
on vient de trop loin mec c'est impossible!
Y'en a une!!
Est-ce qu'on a eu un truc?
Elle est tombée ou pas? Elle est tombée sur le côté putain!
Ho non, on en avait une, c'est tellement dommage! Allez on y retourne!
On va se ruiner! Franchement vous devez être fier de moi!
Comme vous pouvez le voir, l'argent des abonnés, il passe quand même dans
Des trucs importants... M'en bas les c******* j’arrêterais pas tant qu'on
n'a pas gagné un truc et qu'on l'a pas reçu ici dans ce studio mec
Oh putain j'suis bien là... *Voix grave: Nope! *
Oh nan... Nan mais c'est abusé, des fois le délais....
Oh putain... Allez allez allez, on y croit on y croit
On y croit, y'a moyen y'a moyen, y'a moyen y'a moyen
Mais y'a moyen de ouf... *Long silence*
*Long silence et bruit d'insectes dans la nuit*, *Voix grave: Nope! *
Oh nan elle a rebondit... Mais c'est des balles de ping pong
ça rebondit de ouf! , oh c'est la douille
Bon dernier essai sur cette machine de mort
*Long silence de suspense terrible*
*Bruit inconnu de raté* mais what the fuck elle est
Allée direct à gauche, il n'y a même pas eu de rebonds... Il l'a lancé à gauche
Quoi... Bon vas-y nique... Un sac à dos Pikachu
Attends ça c'est quoi comme machine ? Il faut faire quoi ? Il faut juste choper
Le sac et le faire tomber.. Mec celui là il y a grave moyen
J'vous jure celui là, il y a grave moyen.. C'est  parti.. Il va falloir être précis
Par contre là... On est bien on est bien on est bien
On est bien on est bien de Ouf.. Oh même
Au Japon j'aurais pas fais un truc aussi bien.. Oh nan mais là il va se...
Oh putain, j'fais de la merde
Oh mais merde, mais du coup c'est impossible, je les ai
Rapprochés... Mais ils sont collés c'est mort
C'est mort.. On peut plus.. Je les ai collés.. il n'y a plus de place
Pour que la pince... Oh putain l'arnaque
Tant pis pour le sac à dos, on est déçu.. Oh oui alors ça
Mec, alors ça mec, j'en ai fais six
Milliards.. En gros là il faut pousser le truc
A gauche ou à droite au choix.. On va voir si je vais réussir
Si je réussis je suis un héros.. Réservation...
Oh il y a un mec qui est en train de jouer.. Oh je peux pas jouer, c'est réservé quoi..
Ah c'est bon il y a la même chose là mais tu gagnes une figurine
d'une meuf... Allez vas-y on va tenter
On est bien on est bien on est bien !
*Musique de fond* ça le pousse ou pas
Oh la pince elle agrippe
Pas du tout... C'est les mêmes douilles qu'au Japon c'est horrible
Oh putain.. Oh celui là je me le fais
*bruit bizarre* Elle a bougé de un
Millimètre, *rire de Squeezie*
Allez allez Lucas, tu vas bien sur le côté et tu la tires
Normalement en plus c'est grave possible de gagner sur ça
On est bien, je vous jure qu'on est bien
On est bien, on est bien !
Aller, est-ce qu'on est dans l'anneau ?
*Criiii* (grincement de porte)
Ah la douille ! C'est comme au Japon ! Je veux tellement gagner un truc
Bon allez j'essaie un autre, j'essaie un autre
Au moins dieu on peux tenter le One Piece
Allez on y va
Ouais elle agrippe bien
*NOPE*
Je suis sûr le mec dans la vraie vie il est devant la vitrine il voit la pince bouger, il se fout grave de ma gueule mon gars
Ça se trouve il m'entend
He connard fais la tomber stp...Pardon...
Hoooouuuuuuuu !
Hooouuu !
Ho ! Ho ! Ho !
Ha putaaaaiiiin. Je me sens bien d'un coup ça y est
Quand tu sens que t'es sur la bonne voie ?
*Snif- snif*
Arrête-toi vraiment ! Parce que tu vas mettre toute ta thune dans la machine
Hooooooouuuuuuuuuuu
Je te vois toi qui détiens la salle !
Être en sueur, comme ça parce que je vais gagner la figurine
En ayant mis dix fois le prix de ce qu'elle vaut...
OH ! Mon dieu ce qu'elle a fait ! Oh mon y a eu un séisme dans la cabine
*silence total*
Alors devant ce lancer ayant bougé la figurine d'1 mm
laisser moi vous dire que quand vous allez au japon
En fait, quand il voit que vous êtes étranger, ils vont être beaucoup plus sympa avec vous
Donc restez devant la machine pendant longtemps, ok
Vous mettez juste une pièce, vous faites un essai
Vous faites en sorte qu'il vous voit faire un essai
Et la vous faites : "ha nan ..."
Si vous êtes avec votre copine ça marche encore mieux
parce qu’ils voudront vraiment que vous ayez un souvenir inoubliable du Japon
pour amener vos autres copains touristes qui vont dépenser leurs argent dans le Pays
Et puis vous restez devant, même si vous ne mettez plus de pièces
faut faire genre : "Ohh nan ! oh!" même si la pince bouge pas
Et puis au bout d'un moment vous allez voir le mec vous lui dites : "Ouais, un petit coup de pouce s'il te plaît"
Et la, il va vous la mettre au bord
Et la tu sais que ce soir ...
Ta copine va être heureuse et va te gâter.. et va rester avec toi jusqu'à la fin de ta vie
Très bien ça ma saoulé
*RIRE*
Ooooohh ! Elle me plaît celle la
Cette machine me plaît, c'est parti on y va
Oh, il n'y a pas trop de ...
... de lag, ouais voilà super
Je pensais pas qu'il y avais du lag mec je suis dégouté
En faite les UFO Catcher de base c'est hyper dur
Quand il y a du lag, c'est même plus dur, c'est impossible
Je suis en train de lui faire son salaire mon gars
OH !
Oh elle a fait la balançoire
C'est de la merde mais elle a fait de la balançoire
*musique intense*
Je sais pas si je suis content ou si je suis triste
Va si chope bien en plus chope la !
Aller on y crois , on y crois , on y crois , on y crois
La maintenant en plus la machine l'a l'air d'un peu moins laguer !
Il faut que j'aille au fond du première anneau
OUI ! Non je suis au milieu
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave
Sa m'a aidé, sa a tiré dessus
*musique épique*
Les amis il suffit d'un bon lancer, on est bon un seul bon lancer
Sa résonne dans la bouteille, sa résonne dans la bouteille
sa résonne dans la bouteille du coup ça va nous donner de la chance attention
NOOOOOOOOOOOON !
Il la pousser a l'opposé starfoullah
M'en bats les couilles je  vais faire une requête
On va marqué "Please give me the prize"
S'il te plaît donne moi le prix j'ai essayé
40 fois
*rire*
Ok, si le mec a l'historique des essaies c'est possible qui soit sympa
On va voir
Ou alors c'est un connard il va attendre qu'on lâche un petit peu plus de thunes
j'en ai...regarde je le mais dans le vent le truc il brasse juste de l'air mon gars